andy dalton has landed with the chicago
bears this is a subject that they kind
of came up late in the week and chris
isn't here on friday and we want to hear
chris's take especially as it relates to
quarterbacks here's andy dalton and uh a
little clip from his introductory press
conference as the new quarterback
possibly starting quarterback of the
chicago bears
you know you're talking as if you're the
starter what kind of what kind of
assurances have you
been given by the bears uh that they're
done at quarterback that they're not
gonna be making any other moves to bring
in more competition for you
the they told me i was a starter that
was one of the reasons why i wanted to
come here and so every conversation i've
had is uh has been that so
that's the assurance that i've got
we had some fun with this last week
chris when
when he's asked the question you you
talk like you're the starting
quarterback and he scratches the side of
his head i i really need a full forensic
analysis i think he scratched the side
of his head with his middle finger as an
expression of derision for the question
that was opposed to him suggesting that
he's not the starting quarterback but he
is the starting quarterback one year 10
million until they draft someone in
round one if they do we've seen that
happen before sure but money money talks
one year 10 million he's the starting
quarterback for the chicago bears unless
and until they do draft someone in round
one but it at 20 overall there's no
guarantee that there's anyone gonna
that's gonna be there that they would
want no and i just can't imagine that
you know a little like we discussed last
week yeah all signs point point to them
you know they're gonna take the route
right now of andy dahl all andy dalton's
our quarterback try to improve the
offense a little bit
and play through our defense a little
bit like we're seeing washington trying
to do with the ryan fitzpatrick thing i
mean that's what it points to right now
and like you know as far as the drafting
the quarterback thing i just i i i just
don't imagine that happening i just
can't expect them to do a top 20 pick
on you know at quarterback
this year
you don't know what you're going to get
at 20
and you don't know if that quarterbacks
be able to contribute to your team in a
big year for matt nagy and ryan pace i
just don't envision that i don't see
that happening mike i'm with you so i
expected to be andy dalton
unless
there's somehow some way
there's still a russell wilson trade on
the table or something like that right
but that's over so i i expect it to be
dog
yeah i think it's it's gonna be dalton
and they could do a lot worse than andy
dalton and they have
that's the reality for chicago bears
although um
we'll talk later about
trubisky's next landing spot but
trubisky wasn't as bad in chicago as
people thought and dalton wasn't as bad
in cincinnati as people thought it
really is amazing
in this
sport that necessarily presents a
zero-sum game
for all teams involved for every good
team there has to be a bad team for
every team that wins a game there has to
be a team that loses a game there are
going to be teams that are eight and
eight nine and seven or now eight eight
and one or nine and eight once we have
17 games which is going to take some
time to get used to but you're going to
have teams that aren't great and you're
going to have quarterbacks of teams that
aren't great and those guys become the
pin cushions and the butts of jokes they
still have achieved at a very high level
of athletic performance and a lot of
these guys they just they become
just a pin cushion for sarcasm and snark
and memes and i'll admit i've been part
of that from time to time but just like
flacco flacco dalton trubisky yeah so
many of these guys become the butt of
jokes when they've they've performed at
an acceptable level and and chris as you
like to say it ain't just the
quarterback oh there's other guys on the
team that's right the bears are gonna
take a different avenue right now yeah
they're not gonna have the franchise
guys so what you can do it other ways
you know we know that we've seen you
know we saw nick foles win the super
bowl we've talked about we've seen blake
bortles in the afc championship game
we've seen jared goff go to the super
bowl we know what that you can get we've
seen case keenum you know there's been
plenty of teams here that we've seen be
successful you know with less than
quarterbacks jimmy garoppolo is in the
super bowl nobody's going oh that's a
top 10 superstar quarterback hit a
10-point lead against the best
quarterback in the game with six minutes
left so there's more than one way
off two i said golf yeah i know okay you
know i mean yes so uh you just again
it's about building your football team
and playing that way
i know not everybody loves the andy
dalton thing and it's not sexy but the
bears have you know the pieces to play
another way andy dawn's an upgrade as
far as nick foles is concerned at
quarterback he fits i think that system
more he has a little more athleticism he
knows the system
so that's i think a thing they're
looking at and then you know their
defense is damn good too so they're
going to play that style of football
they're not going to make it all about
the quarterback that's what they're kind
of forced to do right now and they're
certainly going to be capable of winning
games with andy dalton the quarterback
and and whether they intended this or
not and if they intended it i say bravo
what they've done with this dalton move
although most people in chicago don't
like it you'll weather that storm you
reduce your expectations going into 2021
and to the extent that that people will
be amazed if they make it to the
playoffs good
good that saves the job of ryan pace and
matt nagy if they make it to the
playoffs and oh they made it last year
so
reduce the expectations
work andy dalton into the position where
he can get it done and uh and maybe he
can five straight playoff appearances
for bengals team that had not been very
good before his arrival and uh uh you
know it fell apart not because of him
from 2016 through 2019. the bears also
in the news for various other players
last week akeem hicks
was given permission to seek a trade
whoa and now the bears are likely to
keep akeem hicks for the final year of
his contract and that one surprised me
chris because you've said it time and
again very different defense when hicks
is not on the field i mean you could
argue he's he is the best player on that
defense uh you know and i know they got
khalil mack who's really good that keem
hicks is
you know i i would say the last two
years i would take akeem hicks as far as
the most valuable guy on that that
defense you know he is a real difference
maker up front it's never going to be
statistical
like whoa this is unbelievable what he
does you know on the stat sheet no the
stats say nothing about the value of a
football player like a key mix eats up
double teams one of the premier
interior defensive tackles and all of
football you know and he is disruptive
so he can get back there and not only
create a mosh pit and hold hold his
ground against double teams and all that
but he's truly athletic enough to where
he breaks in the backfield and there's
an issue that way i i was surprised at
first to hear that they kind of let him
go out of the trade market especially in
a year like this where we're again we're
going with andy dalton at quarterback
this is the year i'd look at it and go
damn well you need the defense this year
then well i'm not expecting 30 points a
game from andy dalton and the bears
offense certainly not and to me you know
they have a chance to be with eddie
goldman coming back from the covert
opt-out and all of that
it
still has a chance to be a very elite
front seven and i i was surprised to
hear that news
i can't help but wonder whether the back
story goes like this yeah team hicks
trying to get more money from the bears
trying to cash in on the value he has
while he still has value one year left
on his contract hey other teams would
pay me more other teams would pay me
more all right fine fine go ahead go
find somebody else to give you more
right and uh we'll trade you and he
didn't so i think that may have been a
valuable make sense ingredient in
getting him to accept
what he's due to make this year with the
bears when no one else was willing to
say oh god for that contract yeah sure
we'll give a fifth round pick fourth
round pick whatever so it may have
helped the bears get akeem hicks in the
right mindset to enter his contract year
and uh and accept the the contract value
that he's getting from the bears allen
robinson accepted the contract value
he's getting from the bear he did what a
surprise well well kenny galladay comes
in for a visit and the next thing you
know the guy who said there's no way no
how he's signing his franchise tag what
does he do chris he signs his franchise
tag
17.9 million
not bad when you consider the galaday's
getting 18 on the open market but alan
robinson now under contract at 17.9
million for one year and we'll see where
that goes from here but uh uh
he was dead set against it there were
reports that morning no way no how is he
gonna sign that franchise tender and uh
once it came out that gallaudet had a
visit then they signed the tender and
and then there was the report that the
bears were still interested in gallaudet
but again it was between 11 and 12
million dollars if they had gotten both
of them right but but
giants paid 18 so that wasn't an issue
but robinson will be there for andy
dalton or whoever to throw the ball to
yeah well i think that was one of those
cases of like wait you're going to bring
somebody in
whoa
that's scary kenny goliday's really good
he's every bit as good as me and he
looks at it that way and then you know
there's the possibility of the
rescinding the the tag and i think also
just the evaluation of what you know
what we've talked about there's a show
you evaluate the current market for wide
receivers he's got you got to be looking
at that going you know what 17 and a
half looks pretty damn good in 2021 off
season with a 182.5 salary cap and all
that let me just take that right now and
see where it goes from here maybe they
can just figure something out long term
wise or maybe it's still the trade
trade and a contract extension with
another team is still on the table but i
think in this year with the way the
circumstances are you signed that and i
think we saw i feel like a little bit of
a land rush
really ever since that point throughout
the league right there was about four or
five other guys who i felt like
they signed they all got in line and
signed it you know you know what this
market's a little crazy this year let me
sign this crap right now and end this
speculation
they've all either signed their
franchise tenders or signed long-term
because
that's the thing the money's just not
out there and uh if you don't get that
when you see guys doing one-year deals
to get a crack at the market next year
you take that one-year deal driven by a
franchise tag calculated based upon past
years and salary cap percentages etc etc
it's not as dramatically affected
although it is still affected by the
reduction in the cap you take that
and you go with it and that's what every
guy who was franchise tagged this year
has done except for the guys who have
signed long-term deals
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports